massive barricade shut down bonanza in
both directions from eastern to 28th
street this afternoon police are still
on scene there tonight after a shootout
with a suspect in that area madison
kimbrough joins us live on that scene
with the latest details
madison
yeah the suspect is now in custody after
an hours-long standoff is happening
around 12 30 this afternoon police
responded to the area of east harris
avenue that's when the suspect opened
fire at police police set up a barricade
and called in back up when swat and
crisis negotiators arrived the suspect
peacefully surrendered neither police
nor the suspect were injured
officers showed tremendous restraint
from being shot at
they did not fire back in an effort to
de-escalate the situation
and protect the citizens and also
bring this to a peaceful resolution
[Music]
it's still unclear the age and identity
of that person while no one was shot one
officer was taken to the hospital after
falling while responding to the call but
is said to be doing okay as you can see
the lanes are open right back up it was
an active scene but it's died down as of
now bonanza and eastern are now open
eastbound going each direction reporting
live in the area madison kimbrough live
local now